[Music]
in this video
we're going to walk through how to close
a cloud billing account using the
console
before closing a billing account
remember that you'll need to be a
billing account administrator
google cloud support cannot close a
billing account on your behalf
so reach out to your billing account
admins if needed
get started by heading to the cloud
console you can start on any project
home page
then head to the navigation menu in the
left hand pane
choose billing and then click manage
billing accounts
select the name of the billing account
you want to close this will open the
billing accounts overview page
in the left-hand nav choose account
management
then click on close billing account
located at the top of the page
the pop-up dialog contains important
information about recommended actions to
take prior to account closing
type the word close and then click close
billing account
the billing account is now closed and
it's indicated by the red banner at the
top of the page
closing the billing account stops all
billable services in
any projects linked to the account
preventing the account from accruing
further charges
final charges for the account will be
fully accrued 48 hours after the closure
and will be reflected on your final bill
based on your current billing cycle
this bill will be the last bill you
receive unless you reopen the account
head over to the documentation to check
out more details